we started with this square right and
we're actually going to do a bit more
construction today
not quite as detailed as last time with
compasses and so on but still
we started with the square okay and then
remind me walk me through what did we do
what did we do well we did it bisection
right we did that okay so that we could
put our compass along this line
and then draw down an arc like so okay
and the reason why that arc was really
useful is because this exact length by
pythagoras
makes this distance here the golden
ratio
and that was kind of cool right um you
can check this length we said that was
one that's a half
that's why that's root five on two in
there
and then we extended it and that well
not that exactly but whatever you've got
in front of you
that's a golden rectangle okay
it's a rectangle where its dimensions
its length and its
width or breadth whichever you call it
they're in the golden ratio
one to five okay and then here's our
follow-up question
i said have a look now at that not just
this big rectangle
but look at the little rectangle that
you added onto the square
okay so we had a look at this distance
here okay
and we calculated what was it this is
the last thing we kind of ended on
anyone got that distance there yeah root
five minus one and two
good okay you look at that and we get
that simply from the fact that that's
that there is room five or two you
subtract a half and that's what you're
left with
okay so here's where i'm going to take
you and i wonder if um in a second when
the three or four of you who did have a
look at it
um we'll see if you got the same result
as well have a look at this new
rectangle with me
this is the ratio
of its sides right just like i've got
this ratio here
i've now got this ratio here okay but
have a look at it and think back to what
you know about cerns because certs are
notoriously difficult to work with but
they're not impossible
okay so when i look at this right i want
to
to work with this i need to get rid of
those serves what would you suggest i do
to this this is a ratio what should i do
to both sides in order to get rid of
that serve any suggestions
here eric multiply them by two and
squared
okay i'm going to have to multiply here
right now you guys know that the reason
why we multiply
and this is what we're going to do is
called rationalizing right is because
serds are notoriously anti-social
creatures
right they don't mix with anything okay
you can put a whole bunch of these
together
and there's nothing you can do to
simplify it they don't like terms
they're all like yeah
i don't like those other guys we don't
mix we just stay apart okay so in order
to get around that we multiply
now what i'm going to multiply by is
this it's a special
term this guy here okay root five
plus one it has a special name it's not
to the c does anyone know what it is
it's called i think i heard it it's
called the conjugate
which is worth writing down if you
didn't know what that was called okay
which just basically means
the other half of like a matching pair
you see these two guys are kind of like
two sides of the same
coin there's a plus one and a minus one
and we see these all the time
so being that i multiply the left-hand
side of the ratio
by this number by this conjugate you
can't just multiply things
on two sides of the equation or ratio
and um
have it different okay so we want to
maintain the same thing on both sides
i have one here so when i multiply by
root five plus one
i just get root five plus one so far so
good
yeah cool now why is it
important or why is it useful to
multiply by the conjugate it's not
random
why is that actually helpful to us yeah
kev because you can get rid of the um
you could just go this five star root
five squared
and then minus once yeah fantastic so
what i've got here
is really the factorization of
difference of squares
we recognize this right this is uh a
minus b
a plus b that's a squared minus
b squared let's see two squares and
we're getting the difference yes
okay so therefore here we'll write it
out in long form
this is a squared
minus b squared right which of course is
not very hard to work out
it's all over two and just for the sake
of i'm going to reverse
the order of my sum over there conduct
them out okay
okay now we can evaluate this in fact
you probably could have evaluated it
here without doing that extra step
this is going to be 5 minus 1 which of
course is equal to
4 four divided by two which is equal to
two
right hold on one more step
look if i divide both sides by two to
make this one because we
like having ones as one of our ratios
i've got one two
well i divide both sides by two right
hold on what just happened what is this
number
this is this is fine this is the golden
ratio
so what just happened i was doing this i
was walking through this whole
construction in order to create
a golden rectangle this big shape here
but in fact
you made two golden rectangles right in
fact the golden rectangle always creates
another golden rectangle within it
alongside a square
okay so this golden rectangle it has
this kind of self-similar
property to it right and that's what
we're going to take advantage of today